the t2 t206 Hest Wagner of
GS let me ask you guys something what do
you call a person who speaks three
languages what aside from being a genius
they're trilingual okay someone who
speaks two languages bil there you go
someone who speaks one American yeah
only 22% of Americans speak a language
other than English at so start learning
a new language this fall and be the
exception not the rule here's a special
limited deal for our listeners limited
time to get you started right now get
55% off your Babel subscription at
babel.com DPT get 55% off at babel.com
DPT that's spelled
bb.com DPT rules and restrictions May
apply hey Tes welcome to another episode
of Dum people to population you
population Goldman Gary Goldman author
two times over no this is my first book
first book why I think you wrote a book
before this Misfit I don't know maybe
cuz I read a lot you read a lot you T
you your comedy is very I would say your
comedy is very well like literature
thank you yes yes so good well we'll
talk about all of that coming up but I
want to jump in right away because I
believe the world is getting Dumber we
at least are lighthouses for it I also
in reviewing Gary's comedy before we
came in here and I think about it all
the time I tried to do your your bit
which is one of my favorite bits of all
time to Jay's son who plays basketball
as we were sitting in Yom Kor Services
inside of a gym at shalev at school I
looked at the baskets that were up there
and I was looking at the baskets I was
like you know I break room my friend
Gary has the best bit about like
Breakaway rims at the Jewish Community
Center and he's like what's the bit and
then I proceed to do my version of the
bit which is
and he laughed and I was like God even
my fa simile of the bit right but you're
very good at tagging so you
probably tagged a couple of things we
always change the name are we the name
of the dentist uh what was his oh they
were all kids who actually played in the
league but also AI liberman who takes
people to Israel to try to get them to
uh immigrate yeah and do comedy there
and then come there so was the name we
always tries to make us members of the
lud party he nuts we need it now more
than so ours was uh the uh the labor
party we need not the leud we need the
labor
the what am I crazy so no so what Earth
the name we always go with Howard showit
Dr Howard shallow Dr Barry
Rosenthal Dr Howard Ronald gross which
was our dentist my orthodontist schlomo
Frankl oh my gosh you're making that up
no I swear to God is [__] awesome he
came came to my taping y yes of course
youv Dr Schmo Daniel I love Daniel you
got a tooth smooth and your teeth are
crooked I we got it's very close sings
in the choir I'm not saying every Jewish
orthodontist drives a Corvette but I'm
saying if you add all the cars together
and divide by the number the average is
a Corvette makes any sense absolutely
vanity plate with a van PL like Dr
Teeth his his vanity plate was say ah m
one or slowmo well his was yeah that was
his not slow-mo slower
slow bu cuspid I hope I hope I might
send this to him I love Dro will love
this weend he fix my smile Dan your
smile have a gorgeous smile and let's
use that gorgeous smile and do our first
dumb story let's do it this was sented
by a of Finance at Dragon
ilm thank you so much which has to be
his company yeah Dragon ilm it has to be
okay right mhm uh okay here's the
headline Florida teacher accused of
biting two students over jar of pickles
wait quite a ride wasn't it wasn't that
a ride please exit to the left we've got
a new group that's going to come in and
hear this headline wait I don't so I
will start with this asking you Gary
please provide a reasonable explanation
why a jar of pickles are in a classroom
I can't understand under what
circumstances would a teacher have a jar
of pickles they're talking about the
dilling process no wouldn't you just say
just one kid [__] loves pickles I
don't want lunch Mom I just want a jar
of pickles oh no I'm saying this is the
teacher's pickles probably right could
be teer show and tell David vast you
next pickles it was something that
started in the Teachers Lounge you got
to try these pi definitely and and no
one is like you know what I don't want
to have pickle breath as I'm teaching
English or Worse pickle finger pickle
fingerz you pull a pickle out and even
if you wash your hands there's a trace
of Dill on your fingers just a little
bit of Dill on the fingers we don't want
you guys you guys like a fried pickle
you ever mess with fried pickles
delicious yeah you know if you get them
a little soggy I don't like they got to
be done right Hamburger Mary's here in
town amazing they do a good job so they
do two pickles that our favorite are you
going to Ann Arbor on the book tour at
all are you going to do probably it's a
place called Zingerman's there it's oh I
love Zinger phenomenal Gourmet gone
there during the an arbor comedy
showcase performances that Years love
that we were just there and so they do
both the two pickles they do one is kind
of like a newish pickle and the other is
like very garlic Dill they're both
unbelievable and there are those moments
when I'm like I could eat like 10 of
these right I would bite two students
over those I would bite two students
over that here we go this happens in
Gary had a question goad is how did you
know sensitive yeah we're on it is there
a because this happens all over the
country at colleges who have a not even
a predominantly Jewish yeah contingency
at their colleges where they will
replace the U in whatever the colleges
with Jew so was University of Michigan
was it ever Jew Michigan or because of
ofm bejw
was Boston and Jew mass and it's like
but then you look at the statistics and
it's like 8% Jewish which is which is
enough to bring about a pagum apparently
right I'm like who who's making this
stuff up Kurt
Schilling is there a predominantly
Jewish school like how the mor brand I
there's University I don't know I mean
Yeshiva is kind
of all right you
ready we of all the years we are
entering a new town in Florida I can't
wait called bartoe Florida which
literally sounds like how a night starts
and ends in Florida bar and then you get
your card towed yes right a Florida
teacher teacher I don't know where that
came from faces misdemeanor battery
charges over allegations she bit two
students over a jar of pickles this is
unbelievable behavior from unhinged
because you can only bite one at a time
I mean she had to bite turn bite
again why don't we have that shirt
bite turn bite again on the back bite
again or on the back dumb people town
but on the
front again Dum people to wear that to a
swinger party dude
okay I'm with this guy the teacher could
stop here Ronda rice R you know crazy
Ronda rice Ronda
ricey wasn't she in the uh Bush
Administration Ronda rice Alisa rice oh
sorry told School administrators she was
quote playing around with students
according to pulk County Public School
SP spokesperson just horsing around I
think she needs to learn what she did
was wrong said Kathy Toro who said
months passed without any action taken
Kathy Toro who shouted that over a fence
at a reporter she wasn't being
interviewed while holding her she needs
to pay for while holding her while
holding her robe
closed I don't have a
strap don't walk away yet
don't walk away she
needs she's a biter and no one's talking
about the TRU the truth is though like
the bite is the most intimate way ever
violence the most intimate level of
violence like when Evander hle when mik
Tyson there was something I'm going to
say sexual about it in in that way right
like it's w it's you mean it's intimate
intimate i this is why most uh my
friends who are cops uh Good Apples um
they said that almost all stabbings get
solved because it's so personal wow you
are that close to a person it's most
random crime is not stabbing all bitings
get solved I would probably agree as
well well we're into one right now two
we're into two we're into two kids got
Kathy Toro said that her nephew is one
of the students and a victim of Ronda
rice I'm going to ask you guys now just
for fun we'll do it in the middle and
you know what we're going to do I want
to try a little wrinkle put something on
the line let's do it the winner of this
gets a pickle gets I got a drawer of
pickles and we're going to start biting
bite now the winner of this gets to do
one plug so something's on the line I
love it okay but it's got to be super
fast as soon as you win you get to give
one plug okay okay ready you guys have
odds on your side although I would love
if Jason just plugged something for his
own family would be great okay plug my
wife's book you should start plugging uh
I'm going to plug I'm going to plug my
wife's book and my son's next basketball
game you got to pick how old is Kathy
Toros nephew who got bit the nephew who
got bit Ronda rice is out here biting
what age children how old are they you
can go you can go last seven seven
seven that is so much more disturbing I
would say uh 13 okay 15 okay one of you
is exactly right okay now you so now you
get to play the game who do you think is
right and in this case if you switch
or stay with yourself but if you switch
and get a piece of the action you also
get a plug okay fine so I think it's I'm
going to stay with 13 because I think 13
is just the age where a teacher feels
like she's losing control of the
classroom and will do something that she
maybe wouldn't normally do like she's
she was moved to bite I want to ask you
Gary is seven an age in which you're
like let go let go of the jar I'm going
to bite I'm going to bite to show what
also you could be dealing with a biter
at 7 so you're just B me I'll bite you
right back sticking or you changing
b or 15 or stay an eye for an eye a
tooth for a tooth I'm going to say stay
with 15 I'm saying we're in also a
vanity plate t t H4 a t t tooth for a
tooth for an orthodontist on a
[Music]
Corvette or just pulling just pulling
pulling te pushing tea pulling teas okay
all of you get your plug ready one of
you is going to get to say it because
Kathy Toro's nephew is also the fact
that it's an ant there's a lot going on
behind the scenes uh glad that she's
taken a participating role in her
nephew's life
is 15 years old something right all
right Randy and I are going to be at the
New York Comedy Festival doing our Twan
show you're invited to come see it on
Sunday November 12th there you go love
it okay TL's 15-year-old nephew is a
student at bar arto middle school middle
school she said in October uh he and
another student so this is old was
working at the school store when rice
tried to take a jar of pickles tried to
take it so the middle school has a store
like a community store sells jar what
are they
Costco like a they got limited space and
they're dedicating we have see your
faculty card pickles kids are not into
pickles we have three erasers or jars
maybe you would buy a pickle one in a
single this how you know that Ronda rice
is not one of the liked teachers because
if it was like the cool history teacher
be like take it
Dr go ahead I'm not looking at it 15 15
we talk about getting the young
generations to care in some ways I love
they care more than any any other
generation before them but like a
15-year-old out an average is going to
go I don't care I care Pi take it these
got pride in that they're like you know
what our lost leaders are going to be if
you take that goddamn get Mrs Rice what
are you doing M her nephew and another
student tried to take the jar back so
they're also not afraid of Ronda rice
cuz I was intimidated by most of my
teachers like give it to me locked the
door she just this is a quote from Kathy
Toro who did found the Toro app mhm she
said quote she just bit them both on the
forearm and of course they released and
she was able to get the pickles but
there's other ways to do that yeah I I
don't know whato she's not wrong we
don't know what she means but she's not
wrong so she bit one of them and the
other one still held on she to the jar
and she bit again yeah she bit once
twice Bitten Twice bitten one twice shot
twice shot I don't normally say this but
learn to manipulate right yeah learn to
manipulate that age you're a teacher you
haven't figured this out oh you got
detention can't you if you don't let me
take we need to weaponize your detention
a little better you can't even Fletch
this on any level and be like a
principal wants me to grab these taking
this to the principal's office yeah like
how why are you going to let a
15-year-old kid stop now I want you guys
I'm going to steal these draw pickles
okay let me do it like Watch What
Happens and how I do it and then I'm
going to come back and we're going to
talk about what you should have done to
stop me okay so let me take them once
right and then you just don't come back
yes right yeah but consequences for for
this pickle theft yes maybe not today
maybe not tomorrow but someday in the
eyes of God yes and for the rest of your
life the students reported the behavior
to school administrators who contacted
Toro Torell went to the Barto police
these guys are probably like oh my
[Laughter]
God although they probably were like is
it a biting like they know ride away in
Florida Rond R how they're like Ronda
rice like how hard did she B you it's
like on Howard St not on Howard ser line
Love Line call um hello and then Adam C
would be like who touched you which
Uncle touch you yeah that was the
unbelievable right but it was it was
nonsense anybody with a baby voice Dr
Drew would say who got to you and for
you and it's just and then you find out
more about Dr Drew and it's like this
guy is a quack yeah I liked when they
knew other things like are you in a
Toyota right now I am in a Toyota right
now like that I want so deep know that
it's like when a psych like you I feel
like you've had loss like [__] I
had lost by the time I was five exactly
what are you in what are you in a cam
yeah no [__] I had loss um go deeper
right okay so then uh go deeper tell
[__] with the teeth with the teeth
go deeper fight deeper you know our old
joke from this is from the 97 this is
from our old TV show about horoscopes
our joke was something good or bad may
or may not happen to you in the near or
distant future we're like that is so
caor that's so Capricorn
Capricorn oh my God but you shine
bright but it's your world you do he
about to tag it it reminds me of it
reminds me of rean with the person who
could talk to dead people and oh my gosh
yes or any pet psychic yeah yeah your
dog says he wants he only will eat pizza
I'm like really me too no way to no way
to disprove it like how are we going to
disprove it dog was to chihuahua in
another life he's telling me that I
can't prove it wrong I can't say no
Kathy goes to the BTO police I imagine
they like hey Kath and then she presses
charges according to an affidavit filed
by the BTO police rice admitted to not
girl don't everything we've already
talked about like her inability to find
a way to get pickles she thinks she's a
im like IM degrad like downgrading what
she did De escalating what did she do
Rice admitted to licking the students no
worse better in some ways worse worse
yeah I like them yeah was a lick was a
bite a licker there was a bite I'm a kid
licker I'm a kid licker who's around
kids I like to lick children's arms
what's so wrong by the way it like in
the old days but they know their nines
don't they they know their
nines they do in the 1950s there someone
I gave that kid a licking that means you
beat the crap out of him that's right
gave him a horrible also terrible and
they kept on taking the 7s could get a
lick you could get early 70s in some
places Sacramento they were giv a lot of
in the 50s I
would take away her teaching license
right she's done she is done because not
just for what she did how she then dumb
to think oh I'll fix it yeah every
decision I'm going to take these pickles
without paying for it the next decision
kid are trying to stop me and I'm going
to now try andot it's just no no but in
four years somebody's going to ask
Rhonda how she's doing she says you know
what it was a
blessing I've never been happier I was
not cut out for this the kids these days
right I can't handle it I mean I any
time in your life you lick them and they
run home listen I got pickle lick that
day any time in your life unless it's
some sort of consensual act or goofing
around with your own kid if you have
resorted to biting yeah I mean come on
that is you you have reached the bottom
of your options over commercial
mainstream pickles these were not
Artisan pickles this isn't
R Crossing Delan not that
best at best I mean now now I will say
this if there are baby
deals I can understand to fight for
those [__] were hoarding some
cornner and you know what and they won't
sell them to me if it's a baby deal or
that thin jar corn sh I'm now on her
side I'm taking those and I'm taking the
L let go you let go and you give your
teacher some respect put some respect
even if she did lick him but I don't
believe she did it's still not
acceptable to me you could have gone
everybody to the world BTO police and
the state's attorney office have filed
two misdemenor battery charges against
rice she set to be arranged in March in
the meantime arranged and deranged in
the meantime she's no longer working at
Barto Middle School she was placed on
paid administrative leave pending she
should not be paid she should not be
paid I'm sorry you don't think no you
can put her on administrative leave but
like to be pissed off guys depends how
much Goodwill she built up over she
might have built up a lot of
Goodwill started this school store
that's right upon completion of the
review rice was suspended for 3 Days oh
my God and relocated to Sleepy Hill
Middle School what is this the
Catholic we're just moving biters who
think licking's okay or question do they
have a store yeah do they have a store
sleep right like hoers right this is her
Redemption story she falls in love with
a 50-year-old male Barbara Hershey I
want to know so bad you do not need to
look it up you two I want to know so bad
what the mascot is for Sleepy Hill
Middle School cuz I kind of want it to
be the Headless Horseman even though
that doesn't that's not a one for one
it's an it's an kabad crane it's a crane
without a head that'd be cool too there
you go okay although she described her
actions as even though kabad crane was
the guy who fought the headless horse
well he didn't really fight he ran ran
ran and he lost that's that little short
goes hard there's some Disney clips that
go hard that was cuz the Headless Heman
it's no like oh banished or learned a
lesson nope he just takes people's
[__] lives and just keeps going right
you think that maybe he would steal a
head put it on his own like I'm going to
take this guy's life and put his loses
his brand yeah true although she
described her actions as playing around
with students we expect our employees to
act professionally and serve as models
of mature behavior all just she didn't
they must set a good example for
students to follow and anything else is
unacceptable P County Public School
spokesman Jason giri wrote in a
statement rice has been a teacher at P
pony schools uh public system for since
2000 so 23 years could be burned out
yeah there are four
prior you just four prior disciplinary
actions in her personal file file I'm
not reading them cuz they're all boring
one's kind of cool she got caught uh
playing on her computer too long and not
doing any work so as a teacher she
probably yeah she probably wheeled in
the cart put a put [__] lamb Before
Time on
and I mean yeah man that's that's Story
one friends wow there you go Story one
down in the not a big enough punishment
for that I'll solve this I'll just say I
licked kids yeah that's that's how you
know like you actually learn more about
the person by their defense their
defense like their you learn how stupid
they are yeah I mean like that that's
where you let someone hang themselves
with their own Rob right all right two
two one story down come back Jay and
we'll find out are we doing your plugs
or our plugs you're and then and Gary
right after this it's dumb people tell
don't go
anywhere hey guys welcome back to the
show Gary Goldman is with us he's got a
new book before we find out about that
and how you can get it support him see
him as he goes on a book tour of of all
we're so lucky he's out here from New
York I literally was like you're here I
know you're doing a show you're coming
to do this and he did and I love it
Daniel tell people where they can see
you how they can see you in October
November in your special and uh near the
end of October you should be just
looking for me running around the
Midwest um if it's off nights I'm
jumping on some don't tells I can't wait
those are always fun and I'll be at yuck
Fest on the 20th of Boston but really uh
this should be safe to say that I will
be in Indie and Louisville and shell
Illinois that's selling out the first
show already did probably second by now
and I will be in Chicago at the Lincoln
Lodge shooting my special and recording
my second album so go to danielv van
kirk.com and then on the 14th of
December I will be at Cap City in Austin
awesome dude amazing I love it uh Daniel
vk.com I love it and please come out to
the special taping make that special for
Dan 1111 make a wish Gary got a new book
out Misfit I'm so excited about it it's
deeply personal and beautiful and I
think if you saw your last special
there's a lot of like stuff weaving
through it yes it's like you it's it's
why we love you but it's all laid out in
the pages let people know about it oh
thanks I I appreciate that and yeah A
Memoir of my life from kindergarten
through 12th grade and so but it's very
specific I have an unusual memory for
the details of my childhood and the
details of I remember everybody's phone
number so whenever I introduce a new
character in in the book I give their
phone
number they made me change legally do
they made me change one number in the
phone number but I but only the people
who had those phone numbers will will
know cuz it just it it underscores the
fact that it does that mean you just
gave away someone else's phone number
maybe yes yeah of course but it's not
only an idiot would be calling these
phone number I agree so yes and and it's
gotten great reviews and the people who
are in it have reach out to me and and
told me they they found it so funny and
enjoyed it when I was reading up about
it it talks about I think in the
description it says your your best and
only friend uh like is one of the parts
of like growing up and like oh yeah I
didn't have like a really close best
friend until I was in in fifth grade I
had I had I'd go over to their house
once and then there was no followup and
and I remember having a kid over at my
house one time and about 2 hours into it
and I was really putting on a good
youing play but I was I was working it I
had a I had this 2XL thing which was it
was you put in eight track tapes and it
pretended it was a computer for you and
and it just was the the the stateof the
art my mom had gotten it at uh from a
neighbor who needed some money so we got
a really good deal on it it was used but
it was still quality and I I remember I
I was clearly dazzling this kid and but
I just wanted to check in with him and I
I this kid was actually at the show the
other night and I said to him I said uh
Neil are you having a good time and he
was like oh yeah I said uh you come back
around Hanukkah this room is going to
look like a
toy you come back here around Hanukkah
but here's the thing I was my my mouth
was writing checks my body wer were very
limit we were very limited financially
and there really was there was a g there
was a gfu Master with a audio component
to it that was in store for me but that
was not going to that that's not going
to bring Pony that was going to bring
Neil back around you blew the W that was
the only time I love the Simplicity of
the cover Misfit if we haven't said it
enough already is the book it's I
appreciate you reading it and because
some interviews I've done they've
clearly only looked at the table
contents they say things like I I see
that you chose to split it up by
chapters interesting
choice yeah and it's my Twain influence
the perspective of you finding at 46
back in
the yes yes the interstitials the
chapters between the chapters are from
when I was 46 living with my my again
your old room I yeah in my old room and
I had been hospitalized for about a
month in the psych ward of of the pain
Whitney clinic at at Wild Cornell and
that was bad but moving back home was
mayy true bottom true bottom that yeah
that's bad but like nobody at least like
at least I'm in a psych wward right now
I'm like I'm at home yeah yeah yeah so
people say uh what have you been up to
I'm waking up in my own bed from high
school the same bed I woke up but it's
like your HBO special like your ability
to channel those moments in those lives
and that mental health work uh like the
the trials of it but then also the work
of it and the perspective of it go
through this so you don't have I go or
you yeah or if you have gone through it
you feel less alone in it less aame I
guess but for two people exactly I go
through it so that I can show you what
this experience was if you don't
experienc this stuff but I'm sure a lot
of people come up to you and say oh
thank you for doing this and thank you
have reached out to you people yeah
people come up in the line to have their
book signed but also I mean that that
special came out four years ago in
October and every day I get an email
saying how it's helped them or they
watched it recently a so nice I think
about the time the the fact that you I
really think this is brave because most
people want their specials and sometimes
I like watch specials and we'll watch a
lot of com specials and I'll be like
this audience sounds too amped up like
this is just doesn't
feel but I'm saying for you to show the
moment of you on stage just fumbling
through and not that's a brave thing for
a comic to do because most Comics would
be like [__] killed it I crushed it
and this what it is you're like this is
how far down and how broken I was at
this point it stands in Star contrast to
the actual thing but it shows how far
you moved in that point it like makes it
that much more real yeah that was the
choice by the director Mike bonfiglio
who who did car and and the the
chandling documentary so he's really
he's extraordinary and he chose that
thing which was was I I always say if I
was on stage I was doing pretty well
right and this video that starts the
special I'm on stage and I'm just
fumbling and just not doing well not
doing well and bombing but I was feeling
well enough to get on St
yeah and and the other aspect of that is
just we watch these specials and there's
like this Heroes walk to the stage and
it's just like please please you're not
going to uh the gladiator fight you're
just going on on stage at the Wilbur
Theater in Boston so I not fighting the
audience toally so so I really I I
prefer the opening where it's a little
bit more vulnerable beautiful and I will
say this to Jay and I have often said
this we discussed with this Dan I feel
like we often times look into the abyss
that is our mental health our own career
where what's going to happen next and
you you say to yourself I don't know how
this is going to turn out and there but
like out of that comes the next thing
that you do and so that's the only
people that I can relate to I can't
relate to people who just go like this
oh I know I just can't I'm like I I
can't have a conversation with you
because you're in the stratosphere tell
me how you think it's going to fall
apart and then we can sit ands we're
good I'm like you're my guy totally I
can I can only connect with the other
tortoises yes yes hairs I got nothing I
got nothing with hair you buddy all
right you're going to win the race cuz
slow and steady again Misfits the book
pick it up you can pick it up anywhere
right digital get a hard copy yes and
and I do the audible version Oh you read
it okay great yeah you have to it's so
good because it's like it's listening to
you do almost like an album but it's a
book
it's like a 10 hour therapy session but
I suggest breaking it up into 45 minutes
or 50 depending on what you're ride if
you're on a road trip let it take you on
the goddamn road trip all right Jay
Let's uh uh and live dates supporting it
too yes Gary goldman.com just go and
find out where he is and go support all
right guys it's been a while since we've
had an epic cake fail story I love it I
love this might be the most epic cake
fail to day can frog frog cake Frog cake
was really that was with Liza SC a green
flat sheet cake with an eye and two eyes
on two eyes on it and you're like you're
passing this off as a frog okay can I
can I say a cake fail that I had
recently yes so I because I'm in firm
belief that the Super Market sheet cake
the Ralph's the Ralph's sheet cake
that'll get you through a lot of
breakups and funeral the best cake ever
because they're using chemicals that
other more fancy bakeries will not use
you're like this is moist and great and
you're like well I know I'm giving
myself answer but like it is so good
right but there's a Nostalgia because
that's what we grew up with we grew up
it is so good right height it's the
right everything everything it's the
right a little sliver H so good so I was
at a birthday thing and like they
brought this cake out and they out and I
ate it and I was like this and in my
mind I think I'm giving a compliment I'm
like this is so good was this from
Ralph's they're like no it's from such
and such fancy I'm like well they are
doing it they're putting chemicals in
here you know that you're not making it
they're making it like Ralph
God and God bless them for doing it uh
here's the headline this is sending from
Adam pton at psky 75 thank you sir uh
Costco cake decorators epic fail leaves
customers and stitches should you be
going to Costco for a cake yeah they
great for a goddamn casket you could you
get the cake and the casket cake now
casket later solid middle class working
class cake yes it's a solid cake uh and
it's also you have to be a member to go
there so like Costco is like membership
for the common man you can go you don't
have to be it's not a country club it's
Costco but you still have a card you
still earn a lot of free food um when
putting you you have oh my mother's
first question when the book came out
was uh will I be able to get it at
Costco you're like probably probably
maybe let's see if we can God willing I
would think they only put best sellers
in there just a pallet of
Misfits give me 40,000 of those 50
Misfits and uh just one Costco one order
puts you on the New York time best when
putting through a custom order on
anything we're often told it's best to
give as much T detail as you can to
avoid confusion you have to better if
you can give a picture sketch for
reference thank you there you go we deal
with this when we want new artwork for a
poster or something we try to give the
most information this is what we're
looking to do and then somebody great
like Jeffrey TY but for one Costco
customer their strategy turn their
custom cake order rather pearshaped and
we're sorry but we're laughing along
with the internet on this one who cares
don't tell me what you're doing
don't insert your own yeah you don't
like when a menu talks to you uh a
Reddit user posted via M mildly
infuriating one of these hyperlinks is
going to connect me to the image because
I have to show it to you I for some
reason when I put the I Believe In You
Post article all right uh it's a New
York Post article that's why this
article sucks uh has shared how the
supermarket giant got their order
completely wrong despite them being very
clear about what they wanted perhaps a
little too clear the Costo customer
provided the store with a detailed
description even featuring a drawing for
what the cake ordered I wouldn't trust
myself to draw godamn really according
to the post uh the customer was very
specific about the order filling out all
the relevant categories on the order
form even offering up a sketch so let me
see if I can get to this get the sketch
I'm curious to see what this is Jay um
they filled out the thing all right
here come on you yeah it'll do it good
job Jay this is actually great
podcasting apprciate old emails
all right this didn't work junk emails
try it uh hold on show how you can use
technology and know how to use
technology you're so this story is you
making fun of somebody doing you're
making fun of someone not understanding
something and you don't even understand
the technology so the all these
hyperlinks don't work but anyway I will
find it I will find it I will find it um
so here's what they wrote according to
the post they wrote no writing SL no
designs is scribbled alongside the
picture uh only one request red frosting
on the perim imeter top and bottom and
any piping the top piping around the top
the which to me would be like it would
look like an unfinished cake yeah in any
case they want any writing nothing no
writing in case anything was Lost in
Translation the customer also scribbled
a big cross and the word nun in the cake
design section on the order so that's
exactly what they did sadly for the
customer and hilarious for us following
online The Decorator took the info way
too literally and offered up this is
with a white slab yeah that's what I was
picturing with the image that they drew
of the cake that's all they're doing on
the inside yeah yeah just a red outline
because they said put something here if
you want anything yeah they thought
maybe that it was so the cake would have
said we don't want anything I made this
for my daughter for her 16th birthday
she was like I was like what do you want
in your cake she's like nothing so we
wrote nothing on the cake you did that
yeah and we gave it to her that's cute
right I have never baked a cake good bit
good bit it's a good it's a good bir kid
birthday bit totally good bit and I love
the Great British baking show let me ask
you this as Jason continues to try and
figure this out but I can't get it to
the thing don't don't you love good life
bits they don't exist anywhere else it's
just a good life bit you and your wife
hang out you and your friends you're
like this one is just for you yes this
is a bit that's just happens in our
apartment people pay for this I'm giving
it to you for fre I'm giving it to you
for free life bit Daniel I'm going to
I'm getting you Safari and I'm getting
on this thing oh my God Jay whenever I'm
on the phone with Todd Glass and a fire
engine police ambulance goes by he says
that's my ride and if it happens four
times on the phone call he says it a
funny bit all right so T glass is the
best at life bits the absolute best the
king of life he brings them on stage too
and I'm going to show you this is what
they filled out on the form they filled
this out on the form on the right side
of the form are all the things that they
said no no we don't want anything on the
cake oh this is on the cake people you
can tell this is just a blank cake look
in the entire section where they're
asking what you want they crossed it out
and it has boxes for you to select what
you want they didn't select any boxes
they did they need to cross it out no
right so they drew like this is just we
want the white the red
piping and then this is the cake that
they
got a cake with their drawing of what
they the middle is it weird to me that
that is like kind of artistic really
completely beautiful if you put that up
in a modern art museum and it is a cake
with that on it i' this fits it reminds
me of something that we've lived with
our entire lives as this in joke from
thousands of years ago when they were
first making cakes yeah that's right I
would believe that this they even the
original the cake makers
up like when Paul Tomkins been about two
as musicians someone like and then they
start cracking up and everyone's like
what's funny about that what's funny
about that he went here and he should
have gone there this is inside cake
inside baseball cake making so what's
great about this is that if you notice I
would love it if this Happ if you notice
in the thing the the rectangle that they
drew to show we don't want anything on
our cake is kind of didn't do perfect
trapezoidal and I'm like what is this
and they copied it perfectly perfectly
was like what is this the International
Lane for a basketball tourament IM
having a wedding like what is this like
I don't may you have an empty what does
it say to you what does it say about you
if I told you that this was a pie it's a
commentary on cake
yes this is this a signf episode I mean
the it's brilliant it's brilliant you
guys it's the emptiness of Our Lives I
couldn't
have I don't think I don't think if you
asked for that you would get it
Theon if you would asked for exactly
that there was no way to get that this
is a one in a million chance but if I
told you upside down airplane I want to
put this on a T-shirt and just say cake
cake just have it say cake underneath it
the t2 t206 Hest Wagner of
cakes what I was going to say is if I
told you that we went to the Modern Art
Museum and this cake was there and every
day you can come and take a slice of the
cake so if you get to the museum late
you might lose it might be just white
you might do whatever you have to get
there early if you want to see and every
day this artist puts a new cake there
it's iway way level I I love it so much
irony and also it's that pipe this is a
pipe that that uh Jason what a
Redemption Journey have but it's
actually can we all just also
acknowledge how I how dumb I am that I
couldn't figure out how to get to it and
then we got there we got there we
ultimately got worth the wait the the
anticipation and the suspense build up
and I got to tell
the
I know we filled the time it was like
filling in a cake but this this is to me
better than if he they would have
followed the directions in
just we we piped around this story and
then you filled it in beautifully I did
in the middle I made mistakes I mean
what a hilarious thing and if you're mad
at these people for putting that on your
cake that's a better cake than you would
have asked for so this cake ends up
serving as a roar shock test of who you
are as a person if you see this cake and
you think it's brilliant and funny then
you're my kind of if you don't get it
then I don't know that I can be friends
with you I would love it if enough time
goes by where you forget this episode
that one of you gives one of the
other that to each other for the rest of
our lives make very Happ is this it I I
want this on a t-shirt just like dumb
people cake I mean let's dumb people
cake dumb cake dumb cake dumb cake good
this is not dumb I don't think I don't I
think it's dumb if you get mad about it
if you get mad were they mad or no yeah
people are people made fun of it and
laugh and I'm way out of all of
your there there's something in this
perspective right like so I don't know
who's dumb in this the people who are
like hahaa you screwed up to an ultimate
level I definitely I definitely don't
think the cake people who made the cake
were doing this as a smart funny thing I
think they're like I think two people
were like they're either High I think
two people are like right or they're
like well definitely one person's like
we should put nothing on this cake
person just put in their two weeks's
[Laughter]
notice there you it's like that's it or
the other they definitely was a
discussion of like I don't think we we
we definitely shouldn't do this the
other one's like no we got to do exactly
what they drew they drew it or they
could have been oh you want to
condescend to us [__] watch me
go right back see that would make
me more exact words GRE exact words
exact words use your exact words so
there it is there it is there you uh
Aaron I'm going to send you a picture of
this so you can drop it put we'll drop
it in the episode where it is it's so
funny that's a beautiful cake I got the
last story it's about one of what a
woman proposes at a town hall meeting it
would make Chad and JT happy it's just
all I'm going to say uh about Florida
and we'll do our plugs on the other side
of this Gary Gman is our guest I'm so
happy he's here it's D people Town don't
go
anywhere guys picture this you're
sitting at your Thanksgiving dinner
and you surpr come on now you surprise
your family by starting an argument I
mean a discussion with a new language
you do it in a new language start today
and get ready to say pardon my French at
Thanksgiving dinner because with Babel
you start speaking a new language in
just 3 weeks I would love to learn how
to say I can't eat any more green bean
can oh God or your passive aggression is
bothering me Uncle David how about that
can you can we pass the roles and pass
on this
conversation guys this fall you can
start speaking a new language just like
Jason said with Babel why because it
works and the thing I love about it it
teaches you how to in a conversational
way how to really speak with people it's
designed for real conversation all
Babel's tips and tools for learning a
new language are approachable accessible
rooted in real life situations and
delivered with conversation Based
Teaching with over 10 million
subcriptions sold Babel is a real
language learning for real conversation
and it really works I use it and I love
it I'm not good yet I'm not I'm not
confident they they don't teach you
confidence but uh you get confidence
byid know but I'm saying like I I'm
afraid to like bust it out yet but so I
went to Italy last summer and I was like
I want to go back to Italy but when I go
back I want to know Italian more than I
do it so I got on Babel and I started
learning Italian and the thing about it
is I just hits on my phone they do
little games they sort of do exercises
to help you out it feels very game
oriented so it's really easy as you go
through it and you it makes you feel
feel very accomplished as you're going
through it and I feel like my Italian's
getting better and I can do it when I'm
taking a walk when I'm walking the dogs
I'm just looking who cares I'm not going
to clean up their poop on the ground
I'll learn how to say in Italian I don't
have a I don't have a bag there you go
and so that's it all right here's a
special limited time deal for our
listeners to get you started right now
and get 55% off your Babel subscription
but only for our listeners at babel.com
DPT get 55% off at babel.com DPT that's
b a BB
l.com DPT rules and restrictions May
apply
around hey guys welcome back to the show
Gary Goldman is here always when we get
together with him there is laughs laughs
about I will say this to Gary Gman
someone want because Gary has a
reputation for those who don't know of
being very nice and nurturing to Young
Comics especially in the New York scene
I don't even know if you this the
Twitter
this was back when Twitter was Twitter
and I think it was during the pandemic
you were giving sort of like no it was
in 200 I think the beginning of
2018 through the through December 31st
of 20 created a handbook this could be a
book you gave just things tips of things
that you did or you do that are like
comedic things that people along the way
if you're like I want to get into comedy
how do I even go about it I don't even
know if that's what you I think you
could use it as that there were just
just like keep journals and write stuff
down and go back and revisit your jokes
and rewrite stuff and hey something
might you might have discarded it but go
back you might be able to rewrite it and
so much about rewriting but it was just
great tips so that's and someone said to
us in a compliment to us which ended up
being compliment to you I think of you
guys as West Coast Gary Gman and how you
are we said it does take two scars to
equal one one Gary Gman is equal is
worth two is a bigger scene that's why
it takes two we took it very as a huge
compliment you definitely that's so nice
to hear well we we know what it's like
coming up you get help and mentorship
from a lot of people and you also get
discouragement and cruelty mostly we got
we got great mentorship and and
encouragement and and it makes the
difference I it was just a way to to
return some of that yeah yeah no one
asked no one asked anyone asks anyone to
do it and so when they do choose to do
it it is out of the goodness of the
heart and it reaffirms your faith in
people it's it's why we love doing our
tag it show it's like our favorite show
to do which is like the
most it's so at once it's very specific
to Comics CU have you ever been in a
green room and you come off stage and
someone's like I love that bit you were
doing have you ever thought of going in
this direction at all at all you're not
and a lot of times you're like oh my God
that's brilliant can I use that sure
take it it's not my joke it's yours you
guys know Mike Kaplan right course so I
have this joke and I think it's on my
last special that isn't out yet but I
had this thing where I would say I said
uh they're using the expression never
again too trivially and frequently it's
It's associated with the Holocaust I
said I saw never again on a yel perview
and and then I talked about the Yelp
review but then my Kaplan came up
afterwards and he said you should say
and it wasn't a Yelp review of the
Holocaust and when somebody says
something and you laugh out loud
immediately you're like oh where can I
go up and try this in a set it just
feels and Crush City yes Crush City not
not Crush City adjacent or on the
outskirts of a suburb of crush City it
was Crush City it's Central Downtown CR
C when you put when you put just the
city into Google Maps that's the point
where it was not just the biggest city
in that state it's the capital love City
and it has a major university so you got
three streams of un it was an early
developed town so they actually have a
Town Square the middle of the square and
Google decided to open up an office
there so it's employing so many people
in question okay so uh so that was our
compliment and for those of you who want
to see us do tag it live we're going to
do it uh at Largo on November 6th um
we've got other dates we're going to do
the Blue Room in um in Springfield
Missouri in second weekend of November
we'll be in New York doing our as Jay
mentioned earlier our Twan show which
again if you're around would love to
have you come to that on November 12th
that's a Sunday night uh we don't have
the theater yet but it's part of New
York Comedy Festival what's the title
it's well I mean we're trying to figure
it out it was called great that people
should definitely go to see something
called twin Dad yeah it's in the
development process so this will be the
second time we put it up with some
changes from the first time we're
excited uh and then hilarities in helium
in Portland and the crocodile in Seattle
all this stuff is supercars.net roit
Mark release Comedy Castle the first
place we ever did back to Denver south
Landmark Club at Comedy Works such good
stuff supers scar.com follow all that
stuff and uh I've got one final story
shall we J into it okay here you go all
right sent in by uh and I think this is
the first P first time this person is
sent in uh Connie molinero hey now at
malano Connie that makes me say let's
tell everybody If Connie recently heard
it tell them how you do it Dan go to
Twitter that's what I'm sticking with
we'll call it Twitter and uh just go #
duml toown sclar brother at Daniel
vankirk and it puts it in order I feel
like malanos is the good Italian
restaurant have you been to malanos have
you tried the the Connie malanos unbel M
Aros are have you had the calamari fre
really at MOS con whatever all right
here you go here's the headline okay
Florida woman calls for sugar daddy and
mommy appreciation day at unrelated
board meeting so she's at a school board
meeting where they're like Evolution and
she's like I have something to say you
know we actually have some new business
you know we really need pH woman at
school board meeting just had a board
meeting calls for sugar daddy and mommy
appreciation day at an unrelated board
meeting so she is a sugar Mommy and is
feeling underappreciated I'm assuming
she is definitely supported by a sugar
daddy you guys have you have you known
anybody that's had a sugar daddy or a
sugar mommy um I've known a couple have
you if you talk to my wife I'd say my
wife and my
kid bye I give my kids
candy um yeah it's an interesting
Arrangement it is an interesting if
everybody's on things you just hope
everybody has agency and is like you
know not calling into love L Anna Nicole
Smith was probably the most famous of
our time but that's
marriage there was that woman from
that's the farthest level that dog show
documentary who was married to that very
old and uh oh yeah what a disappointment
it was when Rap City and white lost that
I
know rap city was a heavy favorite huge
favorite I mean Danny Sheridan had the
betting odds I know just and for winky
to take the the
mayflowers no one no one expected it
although had you paid attention to how
winky was doing on the smaller shows in
the circuit on the buildup to it it's
usually a dog out of the top 10 that
comes Link's always had problem with the
ramps brush the Hoops really hard time
on R let pressure on those tiny
but also to do it with a Handler that
winky was not comfortable with yeah so
there's a lot of talk so how is you as a
handle do are you the type of Handler
that just gives treats all the times are
you the type of Handler that uses
friction to get wi was also more used to
it and that trainer was a I'm not doing
that never they never and you and wik
never gone well with the mor so I hear
that do the second one and you know what
I think of horse no uh the Hollywood
movie with the Tarantino Hollywood movie
with Brad Pit yeah time in Hollywood
when the dog goes when he yeah go I mean
that's just that's just like life porn
you're like oh God I wish that happen so
all right Bon Florida also is wait can I
just say this is I'm talking about the
story isn't this against sugar mommies
and sugar daddies get their appreciation
by paying for it yes yes but to just
give it to them defeats the purpose yeah
but saying we need to recognize we need
to recognize all the things they pay for
that time they pay for that recognition
so they they're indirectly paying for
this too to just give it to them they'd
be like well this isn't really how I
operate I don't know how to accept your
love but it does go towards
mainstreaming the idea the concept we've
gone I people regular people who are not
even cool know of the thruple that's
right exactly like this is we know too
much this woman is dumb but also is she
maybe Cutting Edge like let me normalize
this that's the beauty of this show is
it's taking the Out The Fringe and
normalizing all right so Boon Florida a
woman made an unusual request you guys
are going to love this during a planning
and zoning board meeting that's where
she decided to go in there on this we
posted a video there was a woman who was
like my my sister doesn't talk to me
anymore and my brother-in-law my kids so
and so I mean the longest speech ever
and then there was a person saying
ma' does this have anything to do with
the Burger King that is going up on so
and so and she was like no like you got
to but I kind of agreed with everything
she saying yeah right it happened after
a presentation related to a motion to
approve an ordinance to amend a city
code for the bulk storage of flammable
liquids let me tell you what also is
flamable the relationship between me and
the man who pays for my life the board
chairman asked the audience if anyone
had any questions and that's when this
woman filled the board oh yes the woman
stood up raised her hand and walked to
the microphone do you think she stood up
raised her hand and walked the
microphone raised without being called
on that's what I assume she did I mean
he opened the floor I got a question a
hand stays up the whole way as she walks
all the way to the you know the guy was
like sir and she's just continuing to
walk love it right up there once there
she identified herself and God bless her
as a sugar mama well she identified
herself as Ashley cream right cream
Ashley cream cream Ashley like next up
on the mid stage we got Ashley cream
followed by sunrise and starlight so the
woman gave some numbers so she's coming
with data okay she's about how she
believes Florida had the largest per
capita population of sugar daddies in
the US with Miami Palm Beach and bokeh
with the highest concentration of these
aged benefactors probably
true have you spent a lot of time down
in Florida not much I haven't no I mean
sense but also there's a bunch of NFL
teams down there a lot of professional
athletes that's a that's a thing a condo
for a I would say there's a time in my
life for a side piece where you thought
about moving no I'm just thinking about
it now that you know if some woman in
her 50s or 60s as as I was in my 20s or
early 30s was like no you just go out to
dinner with me we hang out we have a
great time and I'm going to make sure
all you have to worry about is doing
your comedy probably would go I would
I'm not even talking about sex I haven't
I haven't crossed that mental thr but
I'm just talking about just going to
dinner going to a movie giving I I'd be
like done two masses so you know what I
hear when you say that to me that you
don't mind carrying a balance month to
month on your credit card no I don't
want to be beholden to anyone I don't
want to be beholden to well at any point
you just go I don't want to do this
anymore yeah but then there could be
like but I've invested so much in you
yeah you already paid for that dinner
all right d well there's no free lunch
there's no free lunch I'll do hand stuff
oh get out of here at least hand stuff
the woman said they're helpful to the
economy I like it she's making things
it's true you're giving more creating
jobs creating jobs jobs they're
literally giving more people money to
put into the they're like here go spend
this Grand now I'm going to let you're
going to love Ashley cream even more
because she said Sugar daddiy Sugar
Daddy's both gay and straight and yes
even sugar mommies I love that she was
like gay and straight sugar daddy dad oh
big time that's one of the people I know
there have to be sugar nonbinary people
what would they be called sugar asexuals
that' be sugarfree or not even as sugar
freee sugar peep sugar people sugar
people sugar FK sugar folk in Chicago
you would go to the Redhead Piano Bar if
you wanted to find a sugar mama D are
you serious in Palm Beach you go to um
anywhere
Publix I'm done have you ever seen the
episode of getto life where Chris
becomes a male escort and winds up being
sugarm mommed by this really old lady
and it's I just being ordered around I
think it's called just Chris becomes a
male escort if you find it on YouTube
and it's it's as funny of any form of
funniness I've ever seen that show
hilarious way ahead of its time the fact
regular parents still holds up he us his
regular parents and he's a 30-year-old
paper boy lives with his parents and
he's arrogant he's arrogant yeah his
high status when he should have no high
status is brilliant the funniest thing
brilliant all right so and yes sugar
daddies both gain straight and yes even
sugar mommies are responsible for
college educations yes cars homes rents
here's where you're going to jump off
board
Jets and the occasional body enhancement
is what she said I have a picture of her
it's
see her hair I mean her hair is a color
of blond her hair is a color of blonde
that I just I bet you Liberace would
have been oh that's a wig that's a wig
know or guys that's scary that's almost
a ghost I feel like I'm looking at the
ring she's so anyway I love that she
came prepared with facts I love that
she's talking about the economy we get
that we get that road pav and
that's I love popped up in the zoning
laws zoning laws Shay she's like she's
talking about the ayous Zone yeah so
there you go she's got can I ask you one
question is it okay if I hijack to get
out here on this yeah yeah just what
month would you put National sugar Mommy
and sugar daddy many February February
14th yeah right wow you're coming for
Hallmark you're coming for got the sugar
literally coming for you're coming for
Black History Month I don't know that
you can do
February augmenting Valentine's Day for
a day for a day it's not the month but
sugar National sugar Mommy and sugar
daddy day yeah it's a day I just guess a
month and it would be February February
24th all the way it would be a day I me
I would probably put it on Labor Day cuz
it's a lot of work or you do or you do
two days and you do it on Mother's Day
and Father's Day oh that's interesting
or you split the difference difference
sugar right right in the middle right in
the middle point between June 1 June 1st
it does it feels it feels summer to me
you know with the fairs and all that
other sugary food being past on ice
cream there you go will you guys figure
it out I feel feel there's no wrong day
to put sugar dadd no love it all right
you split them yeah there you go that's
a show hey the book is called Misfit
pick it up for Gary Gary goldman.com and
if you bring it to the show I sign it do
that no qu he doesn't even ask a
question you could propose different day
and stuff anyway that's it love you guys
so much and uh oh [__] we got to get
great episode thanks man around make
sound there's more to
oh